from jurassic park and jumanji to kong
skull island and journey to the center
of the earth it's safe to say that
humans have long imagined what it might
be like to visit the prehistoric eras of
this planet's history perhaps it comes
from knowing that the earth was once so
dramatically different back before we
evolved into the dominant species on the
planet then again maybe the fantasy of
traveling back to a land that time
forgot is simply in the appeal of how
cool it would be to see an actual
dinosaur up close regardless of the
reasoning without access to a time
machine you would find it difficult to
make your way back to any era of the
primeval world unless of course you
happen to accidentally stumble upon
scp-1265 also known as the mesozoic
preserve
this anomalous location is an irregular
landmass found within the basin of the
congo river in central africa the oddly
shaped portion of land measuring 50
kilometers cubed is mostly contained
within the democratic republic of the
congo however around 15 of those cubed
kilometers spill over into what is known
as just the republic of the congo the
neighboring smaller country of the two
that the congo is split into
scp-1265 appears at first to be a very
unremarkable area populated only by a
sparse number of tribal villages the
place is mostly uninhabited and in fact
there is very little unusual about the
local flora and fauna that marks it as
being any different from the surrounding
congo basin that is unless you count the
dinosaurs of course
scp-1265 is as its alternate name might
suggest home to a number of remarkable
species that are thought to have been
extinct for many hundreds of millions of
years while they cannot be seen all
roaming around the area like the famous
moment from the first jurassic park
movie once every 30 days these creatures
will appear in a group of approximately
five collectively designated as
scp-1265-a
these dinosaurs are not necessarily
those known to have their fossils found
within africa itself but appear to be
mostly heralding from the mesozoic era
and only those that have evolved in
similar climates to those found in the
congo basin now while you might expect
some of the big names to come rampaging
through the jungle we're afraid that we
might have to burst your bubble you will
not find the likes of the famous
tyrannosaurus rex or the brachiosaurus
in scp-1265
as a matter of fact it's actually highly
rare to find any species there that have
been previously uncovered in north
america according to the fossil records
the most relatively common american
dinosaur species to appear as instances
of
scp-1265-a are the spinosaurus and
kentrosaurus so you're in luck if your
favorite jurassic park movie was
jurassic park 3.
scp-1265-8 dinos aren't all from the
same period of the mesozoic either but
the most common prehistoric eras
represented in the preserve are the
cretaceous and jurassic there have even
been a few triassic era dinosaurs
spotted there as well as several
non-dinosaur reptiles petrosaurus and
similar creatures are known to exist
within
scp-1265 but are not commonly seen
there are perhaps highly surprisingly a
number of dinosaurs that appear as
instances of
scp-1265-a that do not match any known
to be discovered on the fossil record
these new creatures are known under the
collective designation of
scp-1265-lowercase
a instead of the uppercase a the
scp-1265-lowercase a creatures are known
to be unusually aggressive especially
when compared to their other
counterparts that have been encountered
within the preserve most of the time
even carnivorous species that appear in
scp-1265 are normally pretty docile and
show no notable fear or aggression
towards humans unless they are provoked
scp-1265-lowercase a however tends to be
the biggest exception to that rule these
unknown unrecorded dinosaurs will often
charge directly at any foundation
researchers on site when they arrive and
will even indiscriminately attack and
viciously slaughter other animals around
the preserve for a time the scp
foundation was unable to determine the
exact origins of these previously
uncategorized dinosaur species that make
up
scp-1265-lowercase a that is until some
were found within the fossil record
these creatures that became identified
and recorded through the discovery of
similar or matching fossils soon ceased
behaving with active hostility towards
humans in
scp-1265 any and all instances of
scp-1265-a are incapable of leaving the
surrounding area that forms the mesozoic
preserve every time that one of the
dinosaurs attempts to cross the border
that surrounds scp-1265
the creature will vanish from sight
completely dematerializing in the blink
of an eye the
scp-1265-a instance will reappear
shortly after within three kilometers
from the border on discovery the
dinosaurs appear heavily sedated but
still alive the existence of
scp-1265 dates back so far that it even
crops up in local folklore according to
historical records and various reports
of numerous dinosaur sightings over the
years the mesozoic preserve is believed
to have existed for almost 200 years the
scp foundation conducted interviews with
members of local tribes most notably a
resident belonging to a nearby mobashi
village who shed more light on the role
some of the dinosaurs have had on their
tribe's livelihood one tribe's person
noted that while many of the creatures
didn't eat people there were occasional
exceptions one instance of
scp-1265-a that did appear carnivorous
was known as naguma monone and was
described as resembling a large snake
that walked on all fours like a dog with
a big ridge over its back this is most
likely referring to either a specific
spinosaurus or the species as a whole
then there was a dinosaur that the local
people called mokelem
the largest of all the scp-1265-a
instances this was apparently an aquatic
or semi-aquatic dinosaur capable of
breathing underwater and large enough to
cause tremors in the ground whenever it
walked mokele was most likely a word for
the kamisara species there was also
mibele mibelli mibele sometimes called
the beast with planks in its back by the
locals referring to the kentosaurus in
scp-1265
according to further testimony from the
local tribes people the mibello and
mokele both possess features not present
in most modern illustrations that depict
such dinosaurs namely almost all of them
possessed feathers they are almost like
birds in that way the tribe's person
explained but they do not fly the ones
that do fly have no feathers well that
might not sound as though it's in
keeping with the scaly reptilian nature
of most depictions of dinosaurs there's
actually some sense to this you see
dinosaurs are mostly theropods a
subcategory of creatures that evolved
into certain animals still alive today
but we call them birds nowadays in the
1990s at the yishan formation in lyoning
china paleontologists uncovered the
first fossil evidence of feathered
dinosaurs with the bones of a
cynosuroptics being the earliest fossils
to bear imprinting that suggested
dinosaurs had feathers the same local
tribesperson also believed the area of
the congo basin containing
scp-1265 was hexed given how none of the
dinosaurs could leave without vanishing
spontaneously the same happened whenever
one tried to take their meat or their
eggs from the preserve apparently a
number of years before a gang of hunters
had managed to kill a camarasaurus and
attempted to take the creature's carcass
from the area the hunters were forced to
enlist the help of local villagers and
it took the combined strength of all of
them to move it to the very edge of the
preserve of course you can guess what
happened next the creature disappeared
leaving the hunters unable to claim
their prize over the years the locals
have witnessed countless others try to
visit
scp-1265 but not to hunt just to catch a
glimpse of a wandering dinosaur despite
how dangerous that endeavor was the
foundation conducts monthly expeditions
through
scp-1265 studying any changes to the
wildlife and often harvesting any
dinosaur eggs they come across after
incubating them for a time the
foundation's researchers will study the
newborn dinosaurs until they reach
maturity at which point they are
released back into the wild within the
mesozoic preserve naturally this all
occurs on location at site 1265
which is maintained as a wildlife
preserve under the false organization
name the safe and clean planet
initiative during one of these monthly
expeditions one dr neal a foundation
researcher made a series of notes
regarding the prehistoric wildlife
contained within the preserve according
to neal there are a number of trilobites
that dwell in the water these are
ancient arthropods armored precursors to
modern insects and shellfish basically
picture a big underwater woodlouse
apparently the locals would fish for
trilobites within scp-1265
and they taste like prawns when cooked
and eaten while exploring
scp-1265 dr neal discovered a family of
baryonyx a large dinosaur with a long
jaw similar to that of a crocodile that
mostly fed on fish neal observed as
these baryonyx approached a clan of
spinosaurus that according to him looked
more like ducks than anything else
thanks to their coating of feathers the
researcher mourned a profound
disappointment that he and another
doctor dr moore had felt in seeing the
spinosaurus up close
their skeletal structure is completely
unsuited for walking upright and the
less said about the so-called spine the
better scientifically fascinating but as
a lifelong dinosaur enthusiast i must
grieve for such a titan later in the
expedition dr neil discovered the first
of a completely new species of dinosaur
a new
scp-1265-lowercase a instance the
creature was iridescent black similar in
color to a raven and possessed four
wings one on each arm and one on each
leg there was speculation among the
expedition team that this was a brand
new never-before-seen species of
microraptor possibly native to a
continent of asia during a prehistoric
time period being an
scp-1265-lowercase a instance the
creature was noticeably aggressive but
the team was able to capture and sedate
it temporarily naming it microraptor
foundationy next neil and the rest of
the team witnessed a post-osukas a
species of crocodile from the late
triassic era drinking at the edge of a
lake the prehistoric croc was suddenly
attacked by a pack of celephases which
were small carnivores that used their
size and speed to take down large prey
as a group they ate the pasta such as
stripping it right down to the bone like
a school of piranha ripping apart a cow
in the amazon the intrepid expedition
party then witnessed a fight between a
therazinosaurus and a carnotaurus
wherein the victorious thorino
xenosaurus dipped its claws in the blood
of its fallen enemy and used it to mark
its territory scoring trees with
carnotaurus blood finally the group
discovered yet another new
scp-1265-lowercase a instance this time
is serotopicidae these were a subgroup
of dinosaurs that were mainly
four-legged herbivores including the
likes of the famous triceratops this new
ceratopsidae much like many others in
the fossil record possessed four short
stumpy legs but only one singular horn
for defense when the foundation
expedition encountered it it had been
engaged in combat with a pachyranosaurus
a horned serotopic day highly similar to
the triceratops but usually with a row
of horns or horns protruding from its
frill as opposed to the triceratops trio
of horns unlike other members of the
ceratopsidae family this new
scp-1265-lowercase a instance did not
have the characteristic frill instead
appeared to have a pair of floppy ears
at the top of its head the newly
discovered dinosaur was also like the
other
scp-1265-lowercase a instances a lot
more aggressive and gored the
pachyranosaurus with its horn at this
current moment in time it is unknown
exactly how the dinosaurs in the congo
basin actually came to be in scp-1265
the fact that they cannot leave its
borders suggest that they were placed
there with the intention of being
confined to that area but there is no
way of knowing if these dinosaurs were
lifted out of their rightful place in
time to the modern day it could be that
they survived for millions of years
without evolving or have perhaps
traveled to our time from their
prehistoric eras through some form of
temporal gateway
adore through time unless of course
someone spared no expense and grew these
dinosaurs from scratch but who'd be mad
enough to try that right now go check
out you can't resist
scp-666 spirit lodge and you'll never
make it to scp-084 static tower for more
locations it's dangerous to even set
foot in